[Applaudissements]
quel point commun y a-t-il entre une
thèse et un vélo
cette question peut peut-être vous
paraître saugrenu pourtant pour moi à
sept ans existentielle à 35 ans je n'ai
jamais réussi à enfourcher un vélo
et après 6 années d'inscription en thèse
je n'ai pas réussi à finaliser mon
manuscrit
pourtant je croyais avoir vraiment mis
toutes les chances de mon côté pour
parvenir à mes fins
pendant ma scolarité j'ai travaillé
d'arrache-pied pour obtenir les
félicitations à chaque trimestre j'ai
même été plusieurs fois première de ma
classe
aussi lorsque je suis arrivé à
l'université je suis restée sur ma
lancée et j'ai travaillé encore plus dur
souvent d'ailleurs au détriment de ma
vie privée
j'ai donc réussi à obtenir des mention à
chaque semestre et j'ai majorée de fois
a priori j'étais donc promise un
brillant avenir
et pourtant lorsque je suis parvenu à
passer le cap décisif la sélection des
Master 2 je me suis lâché enfin du moins
je me suis plutôt et par pied comme je
n'étais pas vraiment arriver à choisir
entre
le master droit privé et un master en
droit pénal
j'avais fait un choix mi-figue mi-raisin
qui consistait à faire le master Droit
Privé en parallèle du début de crimino
et de sciences pénal du d'anglais est
mon investissement dans une association
qui faisait de l'intervention en milieu
carcéral
alors au milieu de tout ça bien
évidemment mon investissement lui dans
la rédaction de mon mémoire fut relatif
si bien que le résultat a été nuancé et
il ne m'a pas permis d'obtenir le
financement de ma thèse quelle époque on
appelait une allocation recherche
alors je me suis retrouvé perdu mes
projets été remis en cause
et je n'avais pas vraiment réfléchi à
une alternative
alors que je me promenais dans les
couloirs de l'université un peu en
déshérence
je suis tombé sur une affiche
classe préparatoire intégrée pour
l'égalité des chances
comme j'avais été assez subjugué par le
métier de magistrat je me dis que
finalement la vie avait peut-être choisi
pour moi et j'ai donc envoyé ma
candidature
pour intégrer cette classe prépa
et contre toute attente je fus parmi les
16 personnes retenus au niveau national
pour faire partie de l'aventure
et bien malgré ce cadre extrêmement
privilégié de préparation
je dois vous avouer que j'ai échoué
là encore il m'a fallu trouver des
ressources et rebondir seulement voilà
deux sources financières je n'en avais
plus j'ai donc travaillé pendant 1 ans
comme assistant d'éducation dans un
collège en zone d'éducation prioritaire
à Bordeaux
mais comme je ne voulais pas abandonner
l'enseignement je me suis inscrite au
centre de préparation à l'administration
générale là encore c'était sélectif et
j'ai réussi
néanmoins
nous arrivons au terme de cette année
préparation au concours et là encore
j'ai fait chou blanc
bon cette fois on va pas se mentir les
chèques n'était plus une option donc la
mort dans l'âme je me résous à
m'orienter vers une filière qui pour la
cale ignoré finalement pas un grand
aller à puisque sélection sur dossier et
comme dans le passé j'avais travaillé
très dur pour avoir un dossier
irréprochable je réussi à intégrer un
Master 2 droit notarial je trouve très
rapidement un stage avant même l'autre
tension mon Master 2 le donc le fameux
stage de 2 ans qui est le sésame
nécessaire pour l'obtention du diplôme
de notaire
me voilà en stage et là
Stupeur et tremblements
je ne correspond absolument pas j'ai
envie de dire à la fiche de poste en
réalité
mes prédominance comportemental mes
aspirations sont en totale inadéquation
avec les qualités et les compétences
requises pour le métier de notaire
d'ailleurs cette inadéquation est-elle
que cela me renvoie un épisode de ma
jeunesse ou lorsque je m'apprêtais à
devenir réserviste dans la gendarmerie
et que j'ai donc dû faire une
préparation militaire de 3 semaines
j'apprenais l'ordre serré et la
l'adjudant me dis madame on n'est pas au
french cancan
vous imaginez
tu es vraiment ridicule et je me sentais
vraiment comme ça totalement pas à ma
place dans le notariat c'est la raison
pour laquelle bien que j'ai obtenu ce
diplôme de notaire aujourd'hui il a une
vocation purement ornementale il me
fallait donc à nouveau rebondir et la
bien que à l'époque je sois âgée de 28
ans je fais le pari relativement risqué
de me relancer de temps tu es plutôt de
me relancer en thèse
mais voilà vous imaginez avec les
casseroles que j'avais c'est extrêmement
difficile
c'est extrêmement sélectif alors je
raisonne pendant cette préparation mais
comment je vais faire pour essayer de
valoriser
ce temps qui peut paraître un peu perdu
alors j'ai peur d'abord qu'on me dise
que mon parcours est chaotique erratique
et finalement non je décide de ne rien
cacher des échecs que j'ai dû surmonter
à cette commission de sélection et bien
ce fut un pari payant
puisque j'ai été parmi les 21 candidats
celle qui a été retenu parmi 5 autres
pour obtenir un contrat doctoral avec
mission d'enseignement hors
l'enseignement c'était ce qui me faisait
vibrer moi j'avais été tutrice
pédagogique j'avais fait de
l'enseignement en milieu carcéral et je
savais que c'était ma vocation alors
j'étais vraiment ravi de cette issue
favorable
et je pensais que cette fois j'étais sur
les rails je suis en train voyait déjà
le bout du tunnel au bout de 4 ans ça y
est je serai docteur peut-être une ou
deux années plus tard j'arriverai à être
qualifié aux fonctions de maître de
conférences du moins elle était le
discours que je me raconter mais ce
n'est pas ainsi que les choses se sont
passées au bout de 2 ans inscription en
thèse j'étais vraiment rasséréner ravi
de de 7 ans et de 7 ans saignement fin
de l'opportunité d'enseigner qui m'avait
été donné mais d'un autre côté je
n'arrivais pas à avancer dans la
rédaction de ma tête mais voilà dans mon
salon un soir et je ressens
un poids sur ma cage thoracique
une oppression telle qu'elle m'empêche
de respirer
alors je me résous pour la première fois
dans ma vie appeler le SAMU
pour vous dire à quel point j'étais
inquiète de ce qui était en train de se
passer en moi et que je ne comprenais
pas
le médecin qui est au bout du film pose
une question qui me paraît totalement
inadapté il me dit mademoiselle est-ce
que vous avez des soucis dans la vie
sur le moment je ne comprends pas très
bien ce malaise et physique pour moi il
me dit je pense pourtant vous fait une
crise d'angoisse donc ne vous inquiétez
pas ça va passer je raccroche et
effectivement le mal-être se dissipe
néanmoins j'ai été contrainte par cet
événement de faire un arrêt sur image et
de me regarder en face du moins de
regarder en face la situation telle
qu'elle était
tous les enseignements avait été
condensés sur un semestre et j'étais
désormais des vrais enfin en théorie
j'aurais dû être en train de rédiger ma
thèse mais ça n'était pas le cas mais
journée je l'ai passé chez moi enfermé
honteuse de ne pas arriver à rédiger et
pourtant je ne demandais pas d'aide
je pensais que ça allait passer
alors je suis allé voir mon médecin
et évidemment son diagnostic fut le
suivant c'est une dépression donc au
lieu de chercher en moi ou même à
l'extérieur les ressources pour
débloquer cette situation je me suis
contenté me prendre des médicaments
alors autant vous dire que ça n'a pas
porté ses fruits dans ce fut une
stratégie absolument désastreuse
donc j'arrive au terme de mes comptes
mes 3 ans de contrat à l'Université de
Montpellier
et j'ai rédigé royalement 100 pages pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée une thèse en
droit en moyenne c'est 500 pages on est
un petit peu loin du compte il me
restait en gros seins en d'après les
l'échéancier que je m'étais fixé pour
rédiger 400 pages objectif ambitieux
donc en attendant il me fallait tout de
même trouvé un contrat
dataire attaché temporaire
d'enseignement et de recherche et comme
souvent puisque je suis né au Zimbabwe
que grâce à mes parents j'ai vécu déjà
en outre-mer j'ai quand même cette
fâcheuse tendance à vouloir repartir de
zéro quand quelque chose ne va pas au
lieu de tenter le réparer et bien c'est
une nouvelle fois la facilité que j'ai
faire la gueule je me suis orienté
qu'est-ce que j'ai vu un poste
disponible à l'université de la
Polynésie française et j'ai sauté
littéralement sur cette occasion
alors par chance j'ai été la candidate
qui a été retenu et c'est ainsi que je
suis arrivé ici en Polynésie
le choc culturel fut immense si vous
m'aviez vu avant d'arriver ici
j'étais guindé on me trouve est froide
certains me disais même hôtel et pas
vraiment accessible je n'avais en fait
tu as l'air oui mais ici très vite je
m'aperçois que si je ne change pas de
braquer si je ne change pas mon fusil
d'épaule très rapidement ça va
occasionner des problèmes relationnels
alors j'abandonne mes talons j'enlève
mon maquillage et j'essaie de me montrer
son vrai jour la plus naturel possible
je me voit confier un enseignement qui
s'appelle la méthodologie du travail
universitaire et ça a été pour moi une
bénédiction
si vous questionner mes étudiants et
vous dirait que c'est certainement
l'enseignement qui leur apparu le plus
ludique le plus facile et pourtant
l'enjeu de cette matière était majeur il
s'agissait de les aider à se découvrir à
trouver leurs qualités à déceler aussi
leur point de vigilance
à voir ce qui les anime est
et dans ce cadre-là on m'a laissé carte
blanche et j'ai donc à la première
séance organisé un exercice dis
brise-glace en théâtre notamment je me
suis servi de ce que j'avais appris au
cours de mon parcours
et donc j'ai décidé de leur proposer de
venir faire ce que je suis en train de
faire aujourd'hui devant vous
c'est-à-dire se présenter aux autres
aussi bien à moi qu'à leur Camara le but
créer un climat de confiance d'harmonie
et surtout créer du lien entre eux parce
que le droit c'est un milieu aride et
qu'il faut beaucoup de détermination
pour venir à bout de ces années d'études
donc on a besoin d'aller et je me suis
imposé de participer à cet exercice et à
ce moment-là j'étais confronté à un
dilemme
un petit bonhomme vous savez comme dans
les dessins animés me disais Emmanuel tu
ne les connais pas c'est leur première
année à l'université donc tu dois
asseoir ton autorité et tu dois te
montrer
irréprochable et sans faille
et ça c'était plutôt les manuels de
France
la nouvelle Emmanuelle celle
métamorphosée par son contact avec la
civilisation polynésienne avait plutôt
tendance à dire
et si tu montrais à tes étudiants la
partie immergée de l'iceberg celle qui
t'a conduit là où tu en es
et bien c'est cette seconde option que
j'ai choisi et à l'issue de cette prise
de parole mes étudiants m'ont applaudi
j'ai donc compris que j'avais choisi la
bonne option
donc le message que je voudrais vraiment
vous faire passer aujourd'hui c'est que
on a on prend complètement conscience
des effets délétères des réseaux sociaux
sur les publics jeunes en particulier
les adolescents puisque l'on se montre
sous un jour extrêmement favorable si
bien que lorsque l'on ne rentre pas dans
le moule physique qui nous est proposé
ou que l'on a pas la vie rêvée que l'on
voit et bien on se sent mal dans sa peau
mais c'est ton jamais demandé ce que ça
provoque comme effet de ne voir que des
gens qui réussissent allez donc faire un
tour sur linkedin et vous aurez
l'impression d'être le plus nul qui soit
alors
si tout simplement on se délester notre
bonnet d'âne et qu'on se serve de nos
imperfections qu'on utilise nos échecs
pour tendre la main aux autres et leur
dire que c'est normal qu'il leur faudra
de la patience qu'il leur faudra aussi
du courage pour arriver à vivre le rêve
qui les habite donc nous avons tous une
option et c'est désormais ma seule
certitude
la vie met des pierres sur notre chemin
maintenant le choix qui nous revient
c'est de savoir si on va en faire un mur
ou un pont je vous remercie